Hey guys, I'm Annie here with Uniquely Rogue.
And I'm here to help you fellas find the perfect location for your Valentine's date.
South Stage Cellars are having some great Valentine's specials.
They're featuring a special blend called the Romeo and Juliet.
It starts with two separate grapes that individually are incomplete.
But together, they blend for a perfectly romantic taste.
After tasting the best wines in the valley,...
...head on over to the Jacksonville Inn for a romantic dinner and night stay.
Relax with live music and a calming atmosphere.
Once the meal is finished, head on over to the honeymoon suites.
You will be greeted to a warm fireplace, soft pillows,...
...and a Jacuzzi tub to end your perfect day.
I hope these ideas help you shape the perfect Valentine's Day.
From Uniquely Rogue, Happy Valentine's Day!